Merkel oder März beide Idylle oder
Großstadt ja lieber Dorfidylle Großstadt
wenn sein muss weil zum Beispiel das
Parlament da sitzt
ja beides ist nett aber beides muss auch
kein Widerspruch sein Karriereziel
lieber Bundes
Kanzler um Gottes Willen Karrieren kann
man nicht planen das weiß ich gut aus
der Politik Aktien oder Sparbuch ich
glaube beides ist wichtig finanzkultur
braucht es tiktok oder instagram
für mich persönlich eher Instagram
ja natürlich Bratwurst
ja beides braucht es und ich weiß gar
nicht gibt Brockhaus auch online oder
ist das irgendwie jetzt Relikt
vergangener Zeiten jedenfalls Bildung
schadet nie
oder Imbissbude es kommt drauf an eines
gibt es ja in beiden das ist die
Currywurst und das schmeckt mir auch
allen Orten